cette norme
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
dans une récente chronique je faisais
allusion à la vie lamentables de
monsieur raymond le petit responsable de
la rubrique la solution du jeu des sept
erreurs aux échos de la fouillouse et à
sa consoeur échos championne en
obscurantisme plumitifs madame geneviève
porte-à-faux cheftaine de la rubrique
erratum au réveil du pas de calais
ancien secrétaire de rédaction dans
plusieurs journaux parisiens il ya une
vingtaine d'années monsieur francis
c'est celle de ville goy may cry pour me
mettre le nez dans mon inculture en
matière de coki journalistique
savez vous seulement d'où vient ce mot
coquille sans carte il est bien le 19
avril 1911 dans un article du journal
officiel de la république
concernant les nouvelles réglementations
en vigueur dans le commerce des oeufs de
poule il était stipulé que quelles que
soient leurs calibres les couilles
devait être propre et exempte de duvet
au moment d'être exposé à l'étalagé
vous aurez compris que la lettre q du
mot qu qui avait disparu au moment de
l'impression du journal
ajoute mon correspondant dont
l'excellente lettres se perd un instant
dans les méandres vaseux d'une
regrettable grossièreté avec digressions
oiseuses sur la désolation des culs
oublié sur le marbre toujours est il que
le moko qui était né la plus célèbre des
coquilles poursuit monsieur seychelles
revient à un journal de province qui
publia il n'y a pas si longtemps un
erratum relatif à un important article
concernant le conflit social entre les
patrons de pêche et les marins pêcheurs
de plusieurs ports de la côte atlantique
dans son édition de la veille ce journal
avait titré
pêcheurs de poule c'est la trêve on
rectifia le lendemain en caractère
encore plus gros lécheurs de moules
c'est la grève
que des coquilles se glisse dans les
entrefilets de pêche c'est la moindre
des choses mais l'encyclopédique
monsieur seychelles se souvient-il de
sel énorme qu'on cite encore un exemple
de ce qu'il ne faut pas faire dans les
meilleures écoles de journalisme au
début de l'automne 70 un journal
américain tirant à plus d'un million
d'exemplaires avait publié une double
page centrale en couleur sur le thème
sachez reconnaître les champignons il y
avait 20 champignons vénéneux sur la
page de gauche et 20 champignons
comestibles sur la page de droite un
grouillot primesautier avait des tours
dimanche interverti les légendes
sous les bons et sous les mauvais les
lecteurs survivants avait bien ri
dans la journée le jeune employé de
banque christopher grève de tom stone au
texas passe aussi inaperçu qu'un homard
flambé dans un restaurant du coeur
mais que tombe la nuit et voici qu'il se
déchaîne et se métamorphose en superman
de l'inutile
dans la nuit du 6 au 7 mai 1984 il a
battu le record mondial des promenades
cul par dessus tête en réalisant 7400
galipettes sur une distance de 21 km
dans la nuit du 9 au 10 novembre de la
même année il a parcouru 37 km avec une
bouteille de lait sur la tête en 6
heures 12 minutes 23 secondes dans la
nuit du 14 au 15 juillet 1985 il a gobé
47 dur en 2h31 40 secondes dans la nuit
du 4 au 5 mai dernier enfin il a mangé
son vélo en 5h17 battant ainsi son
propre record de la nuit du 2 au 3
janvier au cours de laquelle il avait
mis plus de six heures à bouffer celui
de sa femme
laquelle a fini par se barrer dans la
nuit du 10 au 11 mai avec un grand [ __ ]
qu'il a prise cette fois en 3 heures 20
minutes et 52 secondes
sans bouger les oreilles
plus encore que de sexe l'homme a besoin
de se frotter à la nature
c'est au contact de la nature que j'ai
toujours trouvé en moi la source de
cette inspiration dans l'exquise en
volée sublime aujourd'hui la plupart de
mes beaux-frères
je vais au coeur des forêts ou la biche
bram canton les trains je m'assieds au
bord des routes pour voir passer le
courage le hérisson cref pneus et quand
mes activités m'empêche de quitter la
ville je vais flâner au luxembourg pour
écouter tous et les oiseaux
françois villon en son temps chantait
déjà la nostalgie de la nature qui monte
au coeur du citadin enfermé dans ses
murs
ont une vie bichot bois ont connu faucon
sur mes doigts ont que non le carré soit
hong hong kong
à nature l'écho les cocos l'écologie
c'est au plus profond du maquis sarde
que j'ai couché mais plus belles pages
la sardaigne c'est beau comme la corse
sans les corses et sans les parisiens
giza un grand choc bucolique l'été
dernier à quelques lieues de cagliari à
leur supportable de la tiédeur du levant
où l'on peut encore arpenter la callas
sans se brûler l'espadrille j'étais
aller renifler le matin sous les yeux
calyptus un berger m'est apparu détourna
buisson
noir dans son compte il écorché plié en
deux sur un tabouret bas il était en
train de traire une grande brebis maigre
aux yeux éteints d'agathe usées dont la
laine clairsemé se hérissaient de
chardons mauvais piles et aux chemins
mort
comme il le tournaient le dos je ne
voyais de cet homme éternelle que la
nuque de tortue craquelé sous le casque
est il ne m'entend dit pas approcher et
nate et remplit pas le chant qu'ils
psalmodient au rythme millénaire de ses
doigts sur le pee
wee aa
oui
et oui il chantait pour l'ethiopie et de
son sabot de bois usé frappé la cadence
en ce brillant le pied de droite et de
gauche comme dans le clip vidéo
quant à ces féroces soldats je le disais
pas pour capter mais ils font rien qu'à
mûrir dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
c'est non